all right welcome to Hannity the 45th
president of the United States Donald J
Trump has now been indicted by the Biden
justice department over alleged crimes
that Biden himself uh is also accused of
committee but while the ongoing Federal
documents investigation into Joe Biden
is going seemingly nowhere Donald Trump
is now being forced to appear before a
federal judge on Tuesday to face what is
now criminal charges all 37 felony
counts by the way it's called Uh count
stacking 31 of the counts of willful
retention of National Defense
information six process crimes president
Trump is calling this election
interference at the highest level
members of Congress are now openly
comparing the U.S government to a
corrupt Banana Republic and on this
program the great one Mark Levin called
it a war on the Republic and coming up
tonight we'll get full legal analysis
from our own Greg Jarrett Alan
dershowitz former acting attorney
general Matt Whitaker will also hear
from former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich house Judiciary Committee
chairman Jim Jordan and later stay tuned
for my preview of my exclusive interview
with California governor Gavin Newsom
that's all coming up to this Friday
night but first we begin with a
statement that you hear a lot from the
left nobody's Above the Law they say
there is one set of rules for every
American in fact the doj special counsel
Jack Smith who is Prosecuting Donald
Trump emphasized this during a press
conference earlier today unfortunately
I'm not buying it and I'll explain in a
minute but take a look how did the FBI
view the incident in which Hillary
Clinton instructed Jake Sullivan to take
the marks markings off of a document
that was to be set to her
yeah we looked at that pretty closely
there was some problem with their secure
fax machine and there's an email in
which he says in substance take the
headers off of it and send it as a
non-paper we have one set of laws in
this country and they apply to everyone
there are hundreds of classified
documents on these servers how many
people without a security clearance had
access to that server
I don't know the exact numbers I sit
here
it's probably more than two less than
10. we have one set of laws in this
country and they apply to everyone
110 emails in 52 email chains have been
determined by the owning agency to
contain classified information at the
time they were sent or received eight of
those chains contained information that
was Top Secret at the time they were
sent 36 of those chains contained secret
information at the time and eight
contained confidential information at
the time although there is evidence of
potential violations of the statutes
regarding the handling of classified
information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case we
have one set of laws in this country and
they apply to everyone
one set of laws in this country and
they've applied and everyone really no
reasonable prosecutor would bring
charges against Hillary Clinton even
though Hillary we now know mishandled
thousands of classified documents James
Comey says it which were illegally
stored on her private servers likely
that they believed hacked by foreign
countries are adversaries she then
attempted to cover her tracks by
deleting another 33 000 emails wiped all
of those hard drives uh clean with
something we had never heard of before
called bleach bit and then of course the
blackberries the iPhones they were
smashed with hammers and SIM cards were
removed now take a look at your screen
this is Joe Biden's garage during a
campaign filmed in 2020 next to his
precious Corvette before Biden was
President well at that very same
location right in that same garage right
there classified documents were
uncovered possibly in the cardboard box
on your screen now that's next to Joe's
precious car but more class classified
documents were also found in Biden's
office at his house in Wilmington and
even more documents were discovered in
an unsecured private office at the UPenn
Biden Center at the University of
Pennsylvania in this case Washington D.C
some materials dating back to Biden's
time as Senator University of Delaware
in other words Biden's pattern of
mishandling secret government material
went on for decades there have never
ever ever been any charges against Joe
Biden no talk of even a grand jury with
this special counsel in his case no
information at all whatsoever in the
lead-up to Trump's indictment one League
one day after another so given today's
news I guess there are two sets of laws
one for Clinton one for Biden one for
Democrats and other high-profile liberal
Democrats and another whole set of
standards as it applies to Donald Trump
his supporters any other conservative
when you're a Democrat or a trump don't
pay there guess what you can just say
oops and always forgiven it's that
simple or in case of Joe Biden you can
just lie for example Biden's for that he
never once spoke to his son or his
brother or family about a shady foreign
business deals that's a complete lie
we've proven that over and over again in
fact Biden was pictured with numerous
Hunter business partners including a
fellow barisma board member and now
thanks to Chairman Comer's house
oversight committee investigation we now
know that the trusted FBI Source
accusing Joe Biden have taken foreign
bribes in exchange for policy decisions
well we know a lot more about this
individual we already know that Biden is
vice president was tasked with leading
America's policy in Ukraine during the
Obama Administration and we know that
Hunter was raking in at least 50 Grand a
month from a Ukrainian oil Giant and gas
giant the very same time we also know
Hunter accepted lavish gifts from the
founder of barisma he knows paid a
fortune but yet he admitted on Good
Morning America he had no experience
then he had gifts by the way did he ever
file taxes on those did he ever register
as required by the fire uh Farah act uh
and were there any policy changes what
did he do in exchange for this money and
we also know that Joe as vice president
well he leveraged 1 billion U.S taxpayer
dollars why to get a Ukrainian
prosecutor fired that prosecutor
investigating Hunter's employer barisma
Holdings and Hunter himself for
corruption and Son of a bee he withheld
that billion and in six hours they fired
the guy now according to foxnews.com the
FBI's confidential human Source who has
now been out there this is the James
Comer and Charles Grassley 1023 form
that they've been looking for but that
person apparently detailed conversations
with the barisma executive this
executive reportedly referred to is dumb
but then said quote had to pay the
bidens because the Ukrainian prosecutor
Victor shulkin the one that was fired by
Joe or because of Joe was investigating
parisma and it would be difficult to
enter the U.S market in the midst of
that investigation that was the very
same Ukrainian prosecutor that Biden
forced out in six hours leveraging your
money now the source claims that a five
million dollar payment was directed to
Joe Biden another five million dollar
payment to Hunter Biden and his
foxnews.com reports these were not
direct payments instead they were made
quote through so many different bank
accounts that investigators would not be
able to unravel this for at least 10
years well Jim's call James Comer seems
to be getting there again these are
allegations they are made by a
confidential human Source that's what he
is saying and he worked for the FBI for
years in fact the FBI trusted this
source so much they paid this individual
two hundred thousand dollars plus for
previous intelligence and yet as far as
we know the doj they've known about this
since 2017. they're not pursuing a case
against the big guy Joe they're not
looking at Hunter's laptop where he
complained bitterly about giving half
his income to Pops or paying for pops as
home repairs so after you know pushing
the Russia hoax committing fisa abuse
falsifying documents squeezing Witnesses
over process crimes and of course using
heavy-handed raids to intimidate
Witnesses and then leaking a lot of it
to the Press also pushing Big Tech to
censor the hunter Biden laptop story
that we all know was very real and now
seemingly ignoring of bribery
allegations against Biden I think it's
pretty fair for Americans to conclude
how insulting it is for a doj special
counsel to trot out and lecture all of
us how that we have equal treatment
under the law because I'm not buying
that in this America Joe Biden's America
the sheer lack of self-awareness is
beyond stunning but in reality Biden's
far left doj they probably don't care
they just want to get Trump at any cost
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else